[Musique]
nattawut ne filme pas agressif en croire
que lui que
bonbons izotov
repeindre les autocollants du genre
c'est plus possible il faut absolument
perdre du poids et faire fondre les
calories sinon je vais exploser
qui s'est enlevé j'ai super au rythme
annuel temps levées les super with et tu
peux plus jouer avec était pas content
heureusement que papa est là allez y à
faire un câlin ton papa et powell fin
qu'est ce que c'est beau à voir cette
belle chemise sous son pull c'est des
tigres ça c'est beau tout à fait là dit
il
il reste pour l'apéro dînatoire à la
maison on s'invite ce soir avoir un
crime patrouiller dans les réseaux sort
je suis super g enfin des nouvelles
technologies j'adore les gadgets j'adore
pouvoir les utiliser et j'adore toutes
les fonctionnalités qui vous offre et
toutes les choses qu'on peut faire avec
et dont tous ces gadgets y en a bien qui
est mon préféré c'est celui là je vais
vous montrer aujourd'hui ce que je fais
avec du sport des courses ça a
complètement changé ma vie de tous les
jours et je tiens à préciser que tout
ceci n'est pas du tout sponsorisé par
apple
c'est parti bon là c'est l'instant sport
j'ai téléchargé une nouvelle ville
je l'utilisé pour la première fois pour
faire du sport avec vous on va voir ce
que ça dit commencé l'exercice première
chose normalement on fait pas de sport
engine sont fous
[Musique]
à
c'est choquant
[Musique]
[ __ ] [ __ ] je n'ai pas vocation à et
faites pas comme moi la prochaine fois
vous mettez pas en jean
quand il ya une autre appli qui est
vraiment génial seyoum yann sais pas si
vous connaissez cette appli vous
choisissez vos listes de courses entre
qui peut vous plaire prendre un petit
recettes de poulet au curry ma petite
recette de poulet au curry
j'ajoute directement en cliquant dessus
ça ne la mets dans les recettes de
cuisine et schémas recette du poulet au
curry qui est là je vais dans total mais
ça me colle ma liste pour aller faire
les courses en grande surface mais ça me
met exactement toutes les courses que je
dois faire et c'est en ça que cette
appli est intéressante ça vous donne des
recettes et ensuite vous avez qu à les
mettre dans votre panier
vous allez au cours son métier tout
dedans vous pouvez même préparé toutes
vos courses de la semaine
à quelque chose près c'est vraiment
hyper pratique
en fait le truc qui est vraiment
incroyable d'accès objet c'est vraiment
que sont des facilitateurs de vie vous
faites les choses plus rapidement vos
courses effet votre sport s'est fait
tout est géré rapidement et ça c'est
vraiment génial 19h15 c'est l'heure de
l'apéro
très bien
c'est le moment que je préfère dans la
journée les bills aux dés coquins ce
soit c'est mignon
tu te réveilles pas
[Musique]